what would we be doing if we weren't
doing this what would the media be doing
what would government be doing if
Government didn't keep on getting
clogged up by these you know
cake gate speed gate everything's a damn
gate you know and everyone thinks it's
so original when they put gate after
anything what would the government be
concentrating on what what might it be
achieving if the answer is not much more
then there's even more trouble that
we're in that I thought but my belief is
that we just are horribly misdirecting
our energies the main thing isn't where
are the scandals it's a very
post-watergate thing that journalists
think that their job is to find all the
scandals that exist expose them and then
win all of the awards sometimes there
are scandals then they should be exposed
but the whole of Politics the whole
country isn't just a set of scandals
waiting to be uncovered you know there
is some fundamental failure of the media
in this but the fundamental failure of
the media is a fundamental failure of
government